you
whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners up the FBI
and Seattle PD who busted for poker
players after a two-year
counterterrorism operation and lawmakers
in the Empire State considering a bill
to ban tanning for anyone under the age
of 18 that means no tanning beds at all
even if parents say it's ok but there
can be only one nanny of the month in
this time it's Terry Pierce of the North
Carolina Department of Environment and
Natural Resources they banned from
ordering rare and medium rare burgers at
restaurants regulations demand that
burgers be cooked at temperatures hot
enough to kill all harmful bacteria as
well as most of the delicious taste we
don't want a nanny state that tells us
what to eat it's almost as unamerican as
banning Old Glory at rallies which the
state did last year but you might want
to cut Pierce some slack because
although he heads the department that
enforces the regulation the van itself
was passed way back in 93 and you know
the state reversed that flag ban so
maybe one day North Carolinians will
know the sweet taste of meat freedom we
want a nice juicy pink burger check back
next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your own business
you